every year for the last five or so years
I found myself returning to Polaris the
old RX 470 480 and their derivatives
were cheap widely available used
graphics cards that had that famous AMD
staying power and offered excellent
performance compared to what the new
market had to offer in 2023 however
cracks have started to show in the
Polaris meta leaving room in the market
for a sub 150 pound GPU that can run
anything you thought at it well I think
I found a new contender
the RX 5600 XT was the middle child of
amd's first rdna series gpus launched
103 years ago at the beginning of 2020
for a price of about 250 pounds rdna
marked amd's first departure from a gcn
architecture in almost a decade whereas
gcn powered the eighth console
generation ensuring great support in
games throughout the PS4 and Xbox One
era our DNA would go on to power the 9th
gen it's a reasonable bet then that any
graphics cards based on this newer
architecture are gonna hold up for a few
years like Polaris these first gen rdna
cards are finding their way to the used
Market in large quantities having been
sold off on mass by ex crypto miners the
RX 5600xt can be had on AliExpress for
as little as 120 pounds cheaper than the
woeful RX 6400 and 6500 XT and the
comparatively tamed GTX 1650 and that's
exactly where I got mine this Sapphire
pulse triple fan model seems to have
been exclusive to the Asia Market but
cooler aside it doesn't seem all that
different from the regular pulse model
my specific card did exhibit some of the
things one needs to be wary of when
buying on AliExpress one of the fans was
making a bit of a racket so I unplugged
it to save myself a headache also the
thermal paste needed replacing and
several of the screws showed size of
rust I guess if you can find a similar
price on eBay or a local market you
might take that as a sign that you
should give AliExpress a Miss though I
admit this probably won't be the last
card I buy from them I just don't learn
wherever you get yours from there's
plenty to be excited about with support
for dx12 one a feature set we didn't
know we needed until quite recently and
a modest six gigabyte frame buffer the
5600 XT could be exactly the budget
1080p card that the market needs in 2023
I'll be putting mine for its places in
13 modern games using the moderately
priced gaming PC the mpg PC was just
revamped to include Gen 4 PCI Express
and 32 gigabytes of RAM though I plan on
running Windows 10 until it's no longer
an option
starting with atomic heart I noted in my
GTX 1650 review that there's a steep
drop between performance at 1080 low and
medium that GPU wasn't really up to
scratch at any higher settings but the
5600xt most definitely is alas that
steep drop-off Still Remains at 1080
medium the game can almost manage a 120
FPS average of course you don't really
need an Esports level experience and
against more System Shock than CS go so
you'd probably want to push quality up
to high to enjoy those Sumptuous not at
all disturbing visuals however that will
cut frame rates almost in half the RX
5600 XT can still manage a 60fps average
however and it's worth bearing in mind
that the game's many many interior
scenes are less demanding than this
[Music]
foreign
first party titles are a natural fit for
the 5600 XC and Forza Horizon 5 is no
exception at 1080 high it's possible to
see over 100 FPS even in the very
intensive built-in Benchmark turning up
the ultra has a heavy impact on frame
rates but the 5600 XT can still manage a
70 FPS average I wouldn't recommend
Extreme as the game will need more than
six gigabytes of vram and has a tendency
to nag you about it 1440 high can push
86 FPS but I think that's probably as
high as you're likely to get quality
wise
[Music]
featured titles are so Snappy however a
playtail Requiem is a pretty demanding
title though In fairness it does at
least look the part if you're aiming for
close to 60 FPS you probably need to
think about using FSR as I did a 1080
medium with FSR quality the game
actually averages over 75 FPS with a 1
low close to 60. as this is arguably a
title that could stand to run at a lower
frame rate turning up to high maintains
an average above 60 but we'll see dips
below that during more intensive moments
Halo infinite loves rdna and our DNA
loves Halo this is the Xbox architecture
in the Xbox mascot title after all so it
should be thoroughly unsurprising to see
the game running at 70 FPS averages at
1080 High settings
that being said halo is still one of the
more unreasonably demanding games so far
this generation so 1080 low only manages
100 FPS reaching 120 or 144 in outdoor
scenes and big Team battles is going to
require some judicious application of
resolution scaling
honestly outside of my CPU benchmarks I
haven't spent a whole lot of time with
Spider-Man remastered and I entered this
review Without Really knowing what to
expect as it turns out
quite a lot at 1080 High the 5600 XT can
push almost 100 FPS on average or a
little under double what the GTX 1650
managed turning up to very high sees a
reduction of less than 10 on average
which is a surprisingly small impact
though I think if you're playing on a
smaller screen you might struggle to
notice the difference anyway again this
is a title that can stand to be turned
up to 1440p without any need for
resolution scaling averaging just over
60 FPS and only really dropping at the
point in The Benchmark where the whole
of Manhattan is visible to be on the
safe side it would only take a drop to
high or the addition of some FSR or igti
to keep things running smoothly
[Music]
after the success of Spider-Man I went
into Uncharted with a little more
confidence I decided to skip lower
quality settings altogether and jump
straight in at 1080 Ultra my Benchmark
run turned in a very tidy 85 FPS with
lows in the 70s which should give you
more than enough Headroom for those more
action-heavy set pieces once more if you
want to turn up to 1440 it is possible
though unfortunately not at Ultra
quality I dropped to high settings and
still kept the 60fps average with 53 FPS
1 lows so owners of 1440p displays might
wish to use some upscaling to guarantee
a 60 FPS lock
foreign
God of War doesn't drop the ball here
performance is still very good at 1080
with original quality beating 100 FPS on
average ultra settings isn't quite
possible for one main reason vram both
the previous Sony titles indicated they
would be low on vram at Max settings but
God of Wars ultra settings past six
gigabytes dropping to high does the
trick and still runs at 85 FPS on
average and with lows still well above
60. once more 1440 is doable but I'd
only suggest using the original preset
this is still well under the six
gigabyte limit and can produce 70 FPS on
average so you might find there's room
to tweak settings slightly and turn up
the texture and Shadow quality
[Music]
of course it's not all sunshine and
handjobs and cyberpunk cap to go and
spoil things I don't know if I missed
something but when I tested the Vega 56
last year it actually got higher numbers
than this even without overclocking I
suspect that means cdpr have been
tinkering with the quality presets again
because the RX 5600xt had so far been
doing really well
1080 medium just fails to make a 60 FPS
average though granted only on a
technicality this is 10 FPS less than a
stock of Vega 56 managed last year
1080 High only manages 50 FPS and while
this is of course the naturally perfect
frame rates don't ask me you might want
to add some FSR to appease our ntsc
overlords
[Music]
on the absolute flip side of this
Witcher 3's remaster kinda blew me away
I'd been expecting a much worse
experience based on what I'd seen with
the GTX 1650 but either this is a
heavily Radeon favorite title or the 4
gigabyte vram limit was a bigger issue
than I thought but the 5600 XT more than
quadruples that card's frame rate at
1080i averaging 94 FPS I had to double
check my settings of course this means
there's more than enough room to push
further at 1080 Ultra the 5600 XT can
still reach over 80 FPS and 1440 high
can exceed 60fps on average
[Applause]
frame rates in ugly games like the ones
I featured so far but the Majesty of
first spoken requires something a bit
more potent
no I'm kidding there's there's no reason
why this game's so demanding but here we
are at 1080 standard quality the game
only sees 42 FPS on average and this
could potentially drop way further in
heavier action scenes adding FSR quality
comes close to a 60 FPS average but
doesn't quite hit it going lower than
FSR Q from 1080 is going to look pretty
rough so I'd probably recommend steering
clear of that if possible
[Music]
I kind of ran out of time for testing
OverWatch 2 so I only got a single match
in at 1080 epic I'm sure you could get a
high refresher experience with this card
by dropping to ultra or high and
honestly the visuals don't suffer all
that much as it is at 1080 with maxed
out settings the game runs at a still
silky smooth 114 FPS
[Music]
I've worked out a new routine for
testing fortnite on graphics cards in
dx12 I'll do one pass at 1080 low with
epic view distance and 100 resolution
scaling the so-called competitive
settings then I'll do another pass at
1080 medium again at 100 scaling which
is certainly more visually impressive
without turning on anything that would
overly hurt frame rates and finally at
high settings which in this case
includes such demanding settings as
nanite and Lumen as competitive settings
the 5600 XT is blazing fast turning out
almost 270 FPS on average this would be
a great pairing for a 1080p 240Hz panel
at medium things look pretty but frames
have taken a beating 163 FPS is still
extremely playable especially if like me
you have a 144 Hertz display but it's a
big drop from low
Holly however is an even bigger drop at
1080 you can expect barely a 60 FPS
average and fortnite's standard stutter
is still going to ruin your day what's
worse the newly deepened Shadows make
the game actually harder to play well so
I probably wouldn't recommend this even
if the game we're running at 120 FPS
rather than 60.
[Music]
foreign
I've established that in my opinion at
least there's basically bugger all
practical difference between Warzone 2's
basic and balanced settings in terms of
visual quality so I skipped balanced for
this test basic can provide a little
below a 120 FPS experience so anyone
looking for a GPU to keep up with a
higher refresh monitor than your
standard 60 or 75 Hertz model will
probably want to consider turning on
xcss those looking for a bit more
Fidelity and who are happy with 60fps
should be perfectly satisfied with ultra
as the average only drops into the mid
80s and shadows look way less blocky
[Music]
if you were in the market for a sub 150
pound GPU this year and maybe don't mind
traveling the slightly more uncertain
Waters of the used Market the RX 5600 XT
should definitely be on your shortlist
considering that the RX 5500 XT still
sells for only 10 to 20 less than this
and people still expect to sell the
vastly inferior rx6500
XT for more money I consider this a bit
of a no-brainer
the only question that might be raised
is whether you can afford to spend a
little more if you can justify the step
up to 180 to 200 pounds there are a
couple more interesting AMD options one
of which I'll be looking at in a few
weeks time in the meantime thanks for
watching kindly do the usual YouTube
things if you feel so inclined and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you